Before we say goodbye, we like to play a quick round of!
Drewth or Dare.
(audience applauds)
Yes.
Okay, we have Tina Siganporia. Hi, Tina.
Hi.
Okay, what's it gonna be? A Drewth or a Dare?
Okay, I think
I'm gonna do Drewth!
Okay, I love how you thought about it.
I have a Drewth. I love your eye make up.
Thank you!
You're so beautiful.
The green and the pink lip.
Your whole choices, amazing.
Thank you so much!
You're so welcome.
(audience applauds)
Cute.
All right, so hit us.
Yeah, what's the Drewth?
Okay, so I'm a big TV person,
and if I could choose one show to bring back,
revival, same cast.
Oh, good question.
I would go with "Living Single."
Oh, it's a 90's kind of world, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
So what TV show would you like to see rebooted
or revived in 2022?
"Facts of Life."
(audience applauds)
You take the bag.
You take the bag-
(Drew and Ross sing indistinctly)
"The Facts of Life."
That's good!
Yeah, 'cause you also get that great ensemble.
Yes!
You know, kind of like "The Golden Girls"
and "Sex and the City,"
there's like, someone you identify or parts of you.
I identified through the different characters
and I was obsessed.
I would love to see "The Nanny" come back.
I love "The Nanny."
(audience applauds)
Good one.
And I also think, what about like,
"Little House on the Prairie,"
but done like, kinda dark, you know?
(audience laughs)
That show was dark.
It was? Oh, hello!
It had some heavy themes!
I saw all those bonnets.
(Ross screams)
I know!
Oh, we went there.
Thank you! It's so nice meeting you!
And Ross Matthews!
Thank you.
You are so beautiful.
(upbeat music)